you've to understand you could do
nothing right for the next seven years
start putting it together on your 30th
birthday and still have plenty of time
to achieve everything if you could be
the layer above the internet you are the
world
that's what Amazon Google Apple and
Facebook fight for we fight for being
the best practitioner on that next level
got it that's the game that's where
nobody sees the macro ball this that's
why I'm good but it's the thing I'm
grappling with so I can scrape the
bottom of the barrel and take the rest
of ice cream in a carton coz there's
still some in there a hundred percent or
I can use my energy and time to try to
create provisions for the future and
change mindset one's a morality play
one's a land grab for money well I mean
to me it's the the morality play always
works cuz you end up with more money
everybody's watching let me say this
brother listening to your situation and
ending with this people are watching
yeah so like just keep being right on
the number one thing that has allowed
all my happiness and success is never
wavering from my 100% pure opinion and
having it documented whether it's just
20 people in the room everybody watched
at a conference just be historically
correct that [ __ ] will work out
somebody's watching in a world that's
changing so quickly where everything is
transparent where everything you do is
captured with Flickr and YouTube and
Twitter and quick and kite and things of
that nature where every part of your
movement is captured what's going to
happen is that people that are good that
are awesome that come from the heart are
going to win and people that are bad
that have horrible intentions are going
to lose understand this anything you do
is going to be known you're not gonna be
able to have multiple personalities one
for the chicks one for business one for
this ah it's over you are who you are
now in this world and you need to
understand that very quickly your
personal brand now is completely exposed
to the world 24/7 everybody my friends
is now the media and because of this the
media is the great equalizer and
everything you do will be exposed and
unraveled so try to think very hard what
you want to be to the world the only
thing I do for a living is I reverse
engineer who I'm trying to get to the
only reason I did that video with a
boogie is because I wanted you to see it
all I do is pay attention to attention
right and then I reverse back to what's
happening in culture and that's how I
think about things that's how you think
about selling it's all about empathy one
of the great traits that I wish all of
you can develop is also one of the best
business traits and what makes people
great salespeople
if I actually care more about you than I
care about what I want then I start
thinking in that way when I walked in
here right now even the references I'm
making it's to make it interesting for
you and so when you try to sell your
safety product you've got to figure out
who's making that buying decision and
are you bringing them value not what's
fun for you if you want to do what's fun
for you then sell something that's fun
for you what I'm doing right now is I'm
going into offices because last night I
sent an email around 11:00 p.m. that I
wanted the organization to remember even
though 98% is doing it I want a hundred
percent kindness and empathy throughout
the organization so I'm just kind of
making some inside jokes with the thing
with the company everybody being kind in
here this is a kind conversation
somebody call it I'm so sorry and then
I'll drop that in here and if it needs
to go into 2017 I'll just make note of
that
hi she's checking in making sure
everybody's being kind in this meeting
so everybody being kind in this meeting
everybody being super kind in this
meeting okay awesome
NATO Eli this is Gary Vaynerchuk what
yeah it really is Eli
what so awesome to hear from you Gary
how are you doing I'm tremendous I
wanted to take a quick second and thank
you for buying the t-shirt from first in
line Wow yeah oh I was excited to see it
go up so it's easy for the opportunity
yes I actually was able to get me a pair
of the crushing it shoes off of the
person line drop that you did the other
day on line two I'm pretty stoked on
that you were one of the few people you
were one of those people that actually
got it out one of the five big hit
that's [ __ ] what's up man and I just
want to let you know if you I'm bitten
on them I'm gonna sit on him for a while
ten G's baby ten G's
everybody's gonna laugh and then one day
you're gonna [ __ ] kill it with Daddy
like that that's what I was thinking too
I just been paying attention to what
you're saying and everybody's looking
for the sport for hunting but I'm gonna
hold on to him and gain 20 count I love
it man we'll listen I hope you have the
best day ever thank you I hope you say
that I really appreciate the caller was
offering to hear from you thanks brother
take care what can I answer for you so
can you find me Marcus because that was
so structured yeah I mean honestly don't
beat yourself up you landed in the right
place yeah we're not gonna beat you up
right so I think you're beating yourself
up you're five seconds out
now the end three months you're done
like you did great egg and then now it's
like okay now it's like you feel it's
like a long game looks like alright when
do you finally see the particularly
we're like wow and you never know like
what'll happen like yeah and it's like
the fruit to your labor a fruits of your
labor conversation at 23 to me is
ludicrous you know I get it but but I
want to get you out of it yeah I know I
was 34 years old when I left my dad's
liquor store and like had nothing I
built my dad's liquor store for him like
didn't make that much money like and was
just starting at 34 know what I would
what advice I would get listen I don't
know enough yet but like intuitively
right now in this limited time I feel
like literally making a rule that you
can't think about anything other than
like one day at a time having fun
learning being young for the next 24
months like not allowed that like you
have to you could you can't the wait
here 25th birthday to even start
debating what's happening here would be
monumentally impactful on
[Music]
so you understand you can do nothing
right for next seven years start putting
it together on your 30th birthday and
still have plenty of time to achieve
everything 25 no judging no debating
know even pondering if this is good bad
getting you to where you need to or not
ah
I'm being serious with you I think that
gets you to where you want to get to way
faster than debating it in the
short-term we need to take a little
steam out of the engine and take a
breath a little bit
that's it we'll help you they'll get a
lot more quiet which will create a lot
more room
[Music]